c'est un tandem qui illustre le virage
des corps policiers
émotion dans les derniers vanessa
secrète travailleuse sociale mais elle
est à l'emploi de là police de
saint-eustache l'état ce matin elle
intervient avec les policiers pour une
querelle de voisin paul prévost affirme
avoir répliqué au vacarme du voisinage
pour courir parce qu'il me fait du bruit
tombe j'ai dû me matrat fais toi que tu
trouve hoarau la présence d'une
travailleuse sociale semble avoir
désamorcer ce conflit par certains
policiers qui est à la police et que je
tape en pole et sachez qu'une personne
pour m'aider parce que si le réflexe
était d'appeler les policiers
la solution est peut-être ailleurs et on
va regarder ensemble si c'est une
ressource plus haut niveau du réseau de
la santé au plus haut niveau du
communautaire tenter une résolution de
conflits on pourrait ainsi éviter de
nombreuses à des retours aux policiers
ils sont surchargés par la hausse du
nombre d'appels liés à des problèmes de
santé mentale à saint-eustache
on est passé de 269 appel en 2016 à 370
en 2019 une augmentation de 38% soit
sont pas les mieux outillés pour faire
cesser le travail de poids si c'est tout
ce travail d'une travailleuse sociale
les cas de santé mentale surcharge tous
les corps policiers en général 15% à 20%
des appels récurrents vient toujours des
mêmes endroits qui occupe 80% de mes
patrouilleurs le service de police de
l'agglomération de longueuil s'est donc
joint aux 6,2 montérégie-est deux
équipes d'urgences psychosociales ont
été formés fin septembre composé d'une
travailleuse sociale et d'une policière
elle désamorce des problèmes sociaux ou
de santé mentale
mais certains craignent un mélange des
gens qui un risque de de confondre si on
veut les mandats et les fonctions
sociales c'est à dire de mettre des
travailleurs sociaux dans des voitures
de police
alors que les acteurs depuis des années
demandent moins de présence policière
plusieurs veulent carrément qu'on
réduise les budgets policiers pour
investir plus d'argent en prévention
je suis totalement pour moi contre c'est
comme dire vos service 24 heures sur 24
sept jours sur sept ne peuvent pas
s'adapter ne peuvent pas s'améliorer ne
peuvent pas faire face à la réalité de
2020 2030
longueuil veut que la moitié de ces
policiers est une approche sociale d'ici
dix ans on pourrait même embauché des
universitaires on a développé des
critères sur ceux qui ont des diplômes
sont communaux sont sociaux pour pouvoir
accuser des horizons plus ouvert pour
faire face à des cas comme ici où
l'encombrement pose un risque de
sécurité publique
la prochaine fois je pense que je vais
être revenu avec caroline des enfants en
vie et malheureusement avec la pandémie
les difficultés se multiplient lons
ample soit des dossiers ni à la violence
conjugale la détresse on arrive en
novembre la santé mentale de ressortir
et de plus en plus ici david gêne-t-il
les réseaux canada mon frère